this week on the climate show it's all
about sewage poo if you must and how
projects like this will help keep it out
of our Rivers
[Music]
welcome to the show where this week you
find me 60 meters below London and I'm
down in this extraordinarily massive
project to learn how tunnels like this
could help keep sewage out of the Thames
it is if you like an hs2 for Pooh
but also look at how our appetite for
cheap chicken could be killing one of
Britain's most beautiful Rivers
and hear about the growing Row in Ohio
over a toxic train crash that released
dangerous chemicals into the environment
authorities say there is no risk but
residents say it's making them sick
but first to the intensifying row of how
we keep sewage out of the sea and our
Rivers you've all seen those pictures of
those brown plumes mixing in with the
waves or the current well projects like
this one in London could help and are
they a blueprint for places elsewhere
the problem is they cost billions not
cheap
how do you solve a problem like 39
million cubic meters of sewage water
entering the Thames each year enough to
fill 16 000 Olympic swimming pools
with a very big hole and Associated pipe
work and when I say pipe work we're
talking something you could drive double
decker buses through side by side for
nearly 20 miles
London's Victorian sewers were
engineering marvels of their time
designed to end the Great stink that had
settled over the capital but over a
hundred years later a design decision
has become a major flaw
foul water from our homes flows down
into the sewers but the same pipes also
carry rainwater running off roads and
roofs so downpours can overwhelm the
system and prevent it backing up into
homes it is deliberately dumped into the
river
in London the new super sewer will
instead provide an alternative tunnel
deep beneath the Thames to take those
overflows away stopping them entering
the river
the hope is that no more stuff we flush
will gush from these combined sewage
overflows last year untreated sewage
flowed from them into the Thames
1279 separate times
so when the sewers get full they
overflow and of course when they were
designed that would have been a very
very rare event but today with all the
development with population growth it's
a very regular occurrence and pretty
much whenever it rains to any
significant degree in London it will be
overflowing directly into the River
Thames
the sewage system will now overflow into
here not the river and flow down to be
treated in beckton East London this
enormous shaft here not only provides
access at the moment but when it's
finished this and three more like it
will be massive sewage storage tanks
able to take in any excess in a huge
rainstorm
but with up to 4 000 workers a nine-year
build and a price ticket of four billion
pounds who pays it's been paid for
actually through a kind of Levy if you
like on water bills so that obviously
spreads the cost across many many
millions of of people good systems like
this albeit smaller for smaller cities
work maybe elsewhere in Britain because
this problem the sewage in our Rivers
isn't confined to the Thames yeah that's
right I think it would depend on the
conditions and the nature of the system
and the waterways and so on but there
are many deep tunnel Solutions across
the world
this week the government announced plans
to make it easier to find water
companies for spills inspectors may be
busy though as last year the campaign
group suffers against sewage recorded 14
000 untreated leaks so some of the worst
offenders this
prize with a
water in the thousands as well and we
see it across the country it's unsightly
it's unpleasant but really why does it
matter it matters for human health and
also environmentally as well last year
we collated more than 700 instances
where people have got sick after being
in the water
the sewage is a threat to the natural
world too every day twice a day the
ebbing tide here on the Thames reveals
the lasting evidence of sewage pollution
and here it is you see this it's held
together by wet wipes these only come
through the sewers that's how they got
here and you know what came alongside
them this Reef of wet wipes extends
along this bit of the river and the
pollution that comes with it has wider
impact if you have a big slick of sewage
into the river as it breaks down and
bacterial breakdown the organic matter
in the river they will use up oxygen so
you'll end up with huge areas of
deoxygenated water fish can't breathe so
you'll see them sometimes at the edge
gasping or they just kills fish out and
you can have thousands of dead fish so
there's actually fish suffocating
because of the sewage yeah
cleaning Britain's Rivers sounds highly
desirable but very expensive and a big
row is brewing over who pays the Lion's
Share the government told us they are
committed to improving the quality of
waterways and have put the strictest
targets ever on water companies to clean
up their act but who ultimately pays
water companies by slashing profits or
us through Rising bills
it's not just sewage that's polluting
our Waters but farming too Fraser Maude
has been out on the river Y in
herefordshire seeing how our insatiable
appetite for cheap chicken could be
suffocating one of Britain's most famous
rivers
on the surface the river y seems as
beautiful as ever the problem is What
Lies Beneath
okay so here we are near the riverbank
Jamie just what sort of state is the
y-in today yes well it looks beautiful
doesn't it but sadly on close to
inspection lots of problems increasingly
the way under threat from phosphates
should be teeming with wonderful life
salmon bird species but things are under
pressure
the high phosphate levels in the Y come
from one of the catchment's main forms
of Agriculture chicken farming the
phosphorus Rich manure for millions of
birds raised on hundreds of farms like
this has traditionally been used as
fertilizer but it can run off into the
river that's a kind of you know a burst
of nutrient for the river which sees the
kind of resolve algal blooms happen
crowding out our other species because
there isn't enough oxygen so the decline
of key plant species like ranunculus
kind of the mangrove of the Y holding
onto carbon providing an environment for
invertebrates and smaller species and
then with that destruction uh you know
the rest of the system can't function
the Y used to be crystal clear and
brimming with life not anymore so the
conservationists
one simple indicator of the pressures
that the river y has been under in
recent decades is the amount of salmon
that are in the river back in 1967 8 000
were caught from The River Why in 2021
that number had fallen to less than 330
and some experts fear that in 10 years
time if nothing changes there'll be no
salmon in the why at all
rather than simply being the source of
the problem Some Farms like this were
managed by James Wright are trying to be
part of the solution we're running at 60
over 50. to the end of last crop sheds
are warm enough here are three million
pound incinerator unit turns to
droppings into phosphate-rich Ash that
creates heat for the chicken sheds and a
form of fertilizer that can be sold for
use outside the river-wise catchment in
terms of the why it's a step in the
right direction uh I think you know
Farmers from all livestock sectors and
and the arable sector have recognized
that soil important you know soil
management is extremely important we
need to prevent phosphate-rich soils
getting into our water courses we need
to apply our manures and fertilizers
responsibly of which we're doing and
we're working hard at that and we have
been for at least a decade
[Music]
not all Farms are behaving responsibly
though the environment's agency has
issued hundreds of advisory notices to
those that aren't but there is little
enforcement
the agencies that government Finance to
look after the environment like the
environment agency have had its budget
cut by 75 over you know in since the
beginning of austerity over the last of
12 to 15 years and and as a result of
what's been an emasculation of these
these bodies no Environmental Protection
has really been happening no enforcement
of environmental regulations have been
happening very little monitoring and
inspection of the of the pollution the
sources of pollution has been happening
the environment agency says it is
concerned about phosphate in the Y and
is working to solve the issue one thing
the farmers and the conservationists
agree on is that to provide both food
security and Environmental Protection
there needs to be a more coordinated
approach to the problem
Fraser mode Sky News on the river y
not all the reefs in our waters are as
unwelcome as this one made as it is
largely of Wet Wipes we also have
seagrass Beds which are vital for both
fighting climate change and as a habitat
they have a remarkable ability to draw
in and lock up carbon but ninety percent
of them around our Coast have been lost
in the last hundred years but now the
biggest ever restoration project is
underway
[Music]
special area conservation in North Wales
and we're here today to find the first
sea glass seat
the purpose of this project is
ultimately to restore 10 hectares around
North Wales
restoration project to date but it's
also about informing science
[Music]
oh
it's also it fights climate change by
storing a lot of carbon blocking a lot
of carbons floating around if it's dead
seaweed but instead of seagrass it's
fish scale sources and types of carbon
and the Locking that into the sediment
foreign
there are of course many people who are
doing their own bit to fight back
against pollution on our beaches one of
them is Kirsty Crawford who sent us this
from the west coast of Scotland
hi my name is Kirsty and I live in
Scotland I'm here on the beach today and
I'm with My Dog Ben
so we're having a bit of a beach day
but we've noticed a problem
so Finn is really confused wondering why
we're still up here in the dunes and not
down here where the fun happens
but that's because before we've even got
as far I've already started to spot
there's a problem and the problem is
better so
single use lunch containers
unfortunate enough to work for a marine
charity called the marine conservation
Society who campaigned for and strived
to protect our oceans and one of the
ways they do this is to take a real
focus on beach fest litter the reasons
that it ends up here and the steps that
we can all take to try and reduce that
so there's a program called Beach watch
that I'm going to take part in today so
today as well as picking up all the
rubbish that I'm going to find here on
the beach I'm gonna at the end mark down
the numbers on their service sheet and
find out the numbers of the different
types of litter that are washing up here
bottle face mask
giant blue plastic thing
so this is a wet weight could be a
makeup wipe could be one of those single
you swipes for cleaning the kitchen or
the bathroom these tend to get flushed
down the toilet into our sewer system
out to sea and then ultimately on our
beaches
it does make me worried what we're
putting in here the plastic and the
sewage discharging and the rubbish and
those toxic forever chemicals and it
does make me think twice it's about
coming down here and going for a swim
five second part and Beach watch by
doing Beach creams but also Notting down
your evidence you're able to see how
things are changing over time and
hopefully that means we can see the
positives as well as the negative so we
know when things are getting better
rather than what
after the break we go stateside to hear
about a serious pollution incident after
a train wreck spilled toxic chemicals
into the environment and one year on
from Russia's illegal invasion of
Ukraine we take a look at the impact the
devastating conflict has had on the
environment
[Music]
welcome back to the climate show where
this week we've been hearing all about
our polluted rivers and seas at home but
I want to take you across the pond to
the US now and a village in Ohio called
East Palestine where a huge Freight
Train derailed earlier this month
releasing toxic chemicals into the
environment
this week former president Donald Trump
turned up with thousands of bottles of
his own Trump water to give to Residents
and accused the Biden administration of
indifference to the disaster despite
having cut the regulation on the rail
industry while he was in office
I sincerely hope that when
your representatives and all of the
politicians get here including Biden
they get back from touring Ukraine
that he's got some money left over
so what actually happened here here's
NBC news's Ron Allen who's been
reporting on the ground from East
Palestine
it's been nearly three weeks since this
derailment happened and as you can see
the trains have resumed passing through
this small town of East Palestine it's a
town of about 5 000 people near the Ohio
Pennsylvania border typical small town
America
this incident happened at nine o'clock
at night the residents were rousted from
their homes there was a huge explosion a
huge massive fire clouds of smoke over
the community firefighters and First
Responders evacuating several hundred
residents
urging everyone in this area
uh actually ordering them to leave a few
days later to
and prevent a
wider catastrophe they did what was
called a controlled release of the toxic
chemicals in some of the train cars that
created a huge black cloud of smoke over
the town the governor here said it was a
matter of life and death that people
evacuate and stay away while that
happened
yeah a little phrase death gotten a big
black horse that's what it felt like I'm
seriously really dead
and then a couple of days later the all
clear was giving residents returned to
their homes since that time they have
been feeling very uneasy about what's
happening we've been talking about
moving somewhere different literally
before they even did the controlled like
release the fish were already dying in
the water
it's like I just I don't trust that you
know we we have estimated based on our
sampling and modeling about 3 500 dead
fish across that space there have been
persistent reports of health problems
people saying they get headaches
irritated eyes
runny noses most people can be around
these volatile organic compounds at low
levels
without really feeling health effects
however at higher levels especially over
a longer period of time then we can have
longer term health effects they've set
up a special Clinic
to help people if they have those
problems and the officials are saying to
go see your doctor if in fact you have
some symptoms but they continue to say
that they believe that the air and water
here are safe
the other significant development is
that the EPA the Federal Environmental
Protection Agency here has ordered the
company the rail company Norfolk
Southern to clean up the contaminated
area in no way shape or form will
Norfolk Southern get off the hook for
the mess that they created the EPA
instead
EPA will step in and clean up the
disaster site and build the company just
a tune of three times what the cost
could be the bottom line there are huge
trust issues here residents don't
believe that the rail company is going
to stay here and and take care of the
situation as the rail company has
promised these families have babies and
children and
I'm just so upset
residents are also very skeptical of
politicians and government officials
here so that's where we are now it's
something of a standoff officials saying
it's safe residents not believing them
and waiting to see if in fact Norfolk
Southern follows through on its
commitment to clean up the mess that
they made here
for more on that I spoke earlier to Dr
Erin Haynes an environmental scientist
who will be studying the long-term
impacts on the community I started by
asking her what exactly she'll be
looking at
struggle with understanding their
exposure and
and indoor air quality and also
beginning a start for soil but I I see a
great need to further examine
contaminants that might be in their soil
particularly as gardening season comes
up and people want to get you know in
their dirt and dig I think they need to
know what's in their soil as they do
that and if it's safe to eat the fruits
and vegetables
um and then also what's in the well
water of residents living around the
area over time those contaminants may
not be there in their drinking water yet
but they they may come and be present
even in a year or more
well that raises quite a few questions
I'd like to unpack a bit let's talk
about the soil first of all what kind of
chemicals are we talking about there and
what might be the risks obviously
something you want to study you don't
know but what kind of things are we
talking about that's a great question
and in fact I don't know exactly what
those chemicals are when those gases
Burns those chemicals in the air burn
and during the explosion and then the
controlled burn after they formed new
chemicals in that high heat environment
so those new chemicals have now settled
out and are in the grounds and in those
sediment of strings and that's the first
question what are they
and when it comes to the water you were
saying this might take time is this
literally because it takes time to
filter through once again just unpack
that a bit for me so uh people have
raised lots of concerns and they're
warranted what about our well water
because that does not go through the
typical Municipal Water treatment plan
it's from the well
um I would I'm not concerned about it
the well water being contaminated right
now because all of those chemicals are
on the surface they're on the soil and
they have to go down you know you know
down deep into the soil before they
reach the water table what is the sort
of time scale of an event like this how
big is the aftermath are we talking
months years give me a feeling yeah so
like I mentioned I think this community
needs long-term monitoring uh for their
health symptoms
um we don't know what the impacts are
going to be to
um mothers children uh even to the
wildlife I think they need long-term
follow-up for health and exposure does
this feel like a a pretty you know major
incident to you this this was a major
disaster uh it was a major traumatic
event for the residents
um and I think that there's going to be
long-term cleanup and health monitor
train needed to follow these residents
who should pay for all of this
I love the mindset that uh if you make a
mess you clean it up so
um I look to the uh the railroad thank
you very much indeed
this week marks the one year anniversary
of Russia's devastating war in Ukraine
which of course has had a terrible human
impact and one of our viewers Pete got
in touch via the Sky News app to ask
what damage is Putin's War doing to the
environment to our planet
thank you Pete for the question
um I'm now in Louisville City now uh
besides economic destruction social
destruction and human loss the
environmental destruction is a huge it's
the first it's a destruction of nature
it's a habitat's echo corridors for one
sort of country contamination of
habitats
Soil and Water with mines toxic elements
from munition
River pollution radiation leaks waste in
huge amount
surface and vegetation Forest cover
damage animals killed or run away
estimated damage it's already by 50
billion pounds
and currently almost half of million
hectares of forests are under occupation
or in the war zone
and another 2.4 million hectares have
been liberated but need to be restored
now before we go just a reminder that
you can watch the daily climate show
that's on at 3 30 p.m on weekdays and
remember that you can also get all the
latest climate and environmental news on
the Sky News website or app by scanning
the QR code on your screen right now
and join us next week when I'll be in
Scotland enjoying a dram of peated
whiskey and finding out why this king of
soils is not only important for a stiff
drink but also for our climate
[Music]